and Andrew joins me now I mean it's a
wonderful tribute to your wife and a
special day for you it's gonna be very
hard though isn't it I would imagine
yeah very emotional no doubt my kids are
going to be there and to see well just
to see the level of support we've had so
far it's blown mind-blowing but I think
on the day will be even more so as you
say a great way for everyone to remember
Ruth and with a bigger picture in mind
this is about raising funds and
awareness for rare forms of lung cancer
and to provide support for people who've
come in terms of the terminal diagnosis
and making sure they have the right sort
of professional help to prepare them for
what's to come and is that what it's
about support for people in a similar
position because it is a very rare form
of cancer or is there a chance that you
know more money could eventually lead to
a to a cure both yeah the research you
know I think there have been some really
strong steps forward in terms of
treatment recently but it's still a
disease where most people are diagnosed
at stage four and most people will die
of it we want to change that these rare
forms of lung cancer more more people
experiencing them for some reason we
don't know why that's the case these are
people that have never smoked we need to
understand what's turning these cancers
on and then ultimately how to turn them
off again as well and specifically I
mean is there other specific things that
the money will go towards if people do
contribute and the day at Lord's raises
yeah absolutely so on the research side
we're working with Cancer Research UK on
some specific rare long cancer
associated projects and then on the
support side we're working with Maggie
centers to provide that pre bereavement
support so that's hard stuff that's
people that are coming to terms of the
fact their life is limited and preparing
them and their families what's to come
to say what needs to be said to make
sure the death not a taboo and to make
sure we have the right sort of
professional help to have those
conversations as well good and I mean I
can't remember I can't imagine that
Lourdes has turned red for a day before
so they're gonna wear red caps I think
they were trying them on today and that
people are gonna wear red the spectator
is going to turn red that's the idea
yeah yeah exactly I mean we've got all
sorts of things going on over the course
of the day
it's going to be a real kind of
awareness campaign and for the players
to jump both barrels inning and get so
involved is really special and humbling
for me I mean they have done it
previously with the McGraw Foundation in
Australia which has been an incredible
success and you know make no bones about
it we're trying to copy what they've
done because that's been such an
incredibly successful thing that they've
been able to put on in Australia if we
can do even a small proportion we're in
Australia be amazing yeah because we
have some pictures I think they showed
Glenn McGrath de sydney create ground
that that ground turns pink for the day
and i was there for one of their days I
can remember and it really is it has a
very special feel to it and if you can
recreate that it really will be quite an
atmosphere yeah and hopefully just the
whole cricket community comes together I
mean that's the idea is to to sort of
bind people behind this idea of making a
difference in people's lives and if we
can do that then it will be a fitting
testament to Ruth you know Ruth was one
of the most of charitable people I've
ever met in my life and you know I know
that she'll be looking down and feel
very proud of what we've been able to
put together yeah I mean I've got to ask
you this what has it been like you know
it happened so quickly
yeah about 12 months from diagnosis to
her dying
it's tough as brutally tough you know
our kids are 13 and 11 thankfully we had
some great support and allowed us to
prepare what us for what's to come and
have the rights of the conversations but
I'm not going to pretend it's easy and
you live day by day and it never goes
away but you become better at managing
over time I mean unimaginable loss for
the boys how are they coping I saw you
with with with them at the World Cup
final was it one of one of the birthdays
yeah I mean just the great gift that our
counselor was ever give Ruth and I
before she died as she said listen if
you do some certain things right the
boys are gonna be okay they're gonna
miss their mum tremendously but there's
nothing stopping them having a full and
positive life and that was so reassuring
for Ruth to hear and I've so kept that
message with me since then
and they're doing remarkably well
actually and I mean you know cricket was
very important obviously in your life
England captain director of cricket the
ECB did when this happened put that life
of sport in perspective a hundred
percent I mean I just don't sweat the
small stuff nearly as much the agonizing
decisions I had to make on the
cream-filled really and the greatest
scheme of things are not that important
so I think that perspectives use for
thing but only if you then leverage that
to try and do something worthwhile on
the back of it and that's why I'm so
proud of the work that all the trustees
of the foundation have done the work
that's going to putting this day on you
know we're doing something worthwhile
and positive and if we can change the
lives in the process that would be
incredible yeah and I mean the World Cup
was in many ways your triumph as well as
the players triumph because you did set
in train well you did you did set in
train a process you know it was so bad
in 2015 you realized the problem set in
train a process that did you know bare
fruition as you say I mean I can't
imagine that what Ruth would have made
of that seeing that that day and that
victory for England yeah I mean I'm a
bit uncomfortable about taking too much
praise for it because it obviously the
guys on the pitch went out and delivered
but yeah I think we identified a problem
four years ago that needed changing our
white ball cricket was awful and we need
a game wide change of focus and attitude
to Weibull Craig if we wanted to win the
World Cup the guys went out and
delivered certainly that that day that
World Cup final was incredibly emotional
for me and it did feel like it was just
meant to be and I know that Ruth would
have been just so incredibly excited to
see that and not just see the match
proceeded both our boys jumping up and
down the balcony celebrating that final
run out there it's just the most
extraordinary moment I've ever seen on a
creek field and Ritter have happened on
a World Cup final was just unbelievable
and let's just a quick word before you
go about the ashes and not the best of
starts and what do you think I mean
about Lords
you've got big hundreds there England
don't have a great record there can they
turn it round do you think I think they
can I mean ultimately Jimmy Arneson
getting injured it'll cost us that first
Test match they're under pressure this
match they have to win you know they
can't afford not to lose right to play
well I think so you know I mean you have
that all that medical advice there
you've got to follow it but these things
happen or in Korea field just need to
start this game well and and get on top
of Australia and there's some
vulnerabilities for us to exploit